Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Oxygen Not Included.
So, we've got a really unique situation going on here.
We've got water flowing down...
And I need to prioritize another, like, channel for it to go down.
Or else it's just going to pool there.
So... I don't know why I don't just make that a Nine Dig.
Okay, so they're going to dig that out.
They need to get food, obviously. The next step has to be food after these repairs get made.
They're breathing nothing but contaminated oxygen, which sucks. I know.
But there's not a whole lot that I can do about it right now.
Ugh, but yeah. I immediately have t- (interrupted) That was JUST about to start, oh boy.
But at least we're going somewhere.
So with... with clean water, with clean water (repeating frantically)
Comes...
Oxygen through water.
Like formations/things/stuff... Whatever the technical term you wanna call that, that's what it is.
Ah jeez, these are broken too.
What else is broken? This is broken. Jeezums.
Okay, so now water, hopefully anyway, should go there.
Lemme try to make some sort of a...
Okay well, they can't get there now which sucks, but okay.
Oh God. People are starving. No, don't starve and go to bed! No! Come on.
Just make food God damnit, make foooood!
Oh my God. Make food, make food, make food.
I know everyone's hungry, I'm aware.
I'm aware of this.
Aw man...
At least this is making good water.
It's actually pumping out three... like about three kilograms of water a second, which is a lot of water.
A good, good, good amount of water.
I mean it's uh, it's still gonna take some time before it gets through all of this, but...
At least we'll have that.
And then I'm gonna cut through here,
get another channel of contaminated water through there,
now that I can deal with that okay.
Jeez.
Get water. Just nothing but food. Just get food, don't die.
Get food, get food, get food food food, get food. (little rhythm)
Get food. Maybe I could just turn these off since they...
They won't be a draw on power since they don't have any- oh, I'll just keep...
These two on, and that way these will stay off.
So that...
Uhhhh....
So these will stay off so they don't draw excess power.
Well go get food, don't starve, go get food!
There should be no other priority besides...
Just getting food.
Even these need to be set to six.
Set to six.
Don't... don't starve just for that.
I'm gonna put food at a constant seven.
That way, I don't need to change it back and forth every time.
Please tell me we're not going to die.
Zeke, Bubbles, eat.
Zeke, Bubbles, eat!
ZEKE, BUBBLES, EAT!
Bubbles eat, eat Bubbles.
Bubbles, eat. Bubbles, have you eaten?
Bubbles why have you not eaten? (stressed Mark)
Zeke, eat! What are you doing?
Jesus, get some power.
Oh my God, this is absurd.
Ohhhhh, fuck.
Don't die, don't die, don't die. It's right there, it's so easy.
(stressed father) Zeke and Bubbles, why have you not eaten yet?
BUBBLES! Just go eat! Are you kidding me??
This... what the fuck is going on here?
Why are they not eating?
Why are they not eating? I am... I can't do anything else to make them eat!
Oh God Bubbles, why are YOU repairing!?
There's six people starving now.
There should be no reason for six people to starve now.
Why are six people starving now?
Just eat!
Who died!? God dammit!
Zeke! What the fuck?!
Zeke, are you God damn serious??
Zeke, there was no reason to do that- don't tell me that...
God dammit Bubbles!
What the fuck!
Are you fucking serious!
Don't go to BED!
What is happening to these people?
WHY ARE THEY NOT EATING?
Why the FUCK aren't they eating?
Just as I was about to get everything underway.
Just as I was getting things going.
It's like, it's a non-stop...
Battle, every single Goddamn second of this.
It's just a constant battle.
There's no winning.
There's just no winning...
There's just one person- Olive, do not die. Olive...
Olive, please.
Olive please, just don't die.
Olive, don't do it please.
Eat something.
Eat something!
EAT SOMETHING!
Stop fetching water and EAT something!
Olive you can't die. I know you, Olive.
You don't die!
Olive EAT something!!!!
Stop being selfless for one second, and EAT something!
(laughs) Olive, you're so selfless!
What are you doing?
Olive... Olive, please, just eat something.
Olive, what are you doing?
Olive....
Just EAT something!
Am I literally just gonna watch Olive starve to death as she constantly tries to provide everyone else with food?
Olive, just please...
Olive.
Olive...
Cannot reach food.
Why.
She's dead.
(Mark is very sad now)
(He tried so hard... but his children are dying)
Fuck...
The only thing I can do is...
And the problem is, we're running out of water.
That is the main issue.
I can't grow things here.
Because it's too hot.
And I can't produce oxygen.
'Cause I don't have enough water.
And...
I can't send them to get more slime.
"Cause... they'll starve.
So, the problem is...
It's using tons of water.
It's using TONS of water.
Not just a little bit of water. It's using TONS of water.
So the problem wasn't the number of Microbe Mushers.
The problem was getting that water up there, to them.
So then...
So then the answer isn't having more of them up here, it's having...
More of them closer to the water. But I'm almost out of water anyway.
The fuck. What's the answer here?
Everyone is going to starve. I can't fucking make...
I can't make any God damn Mealwood.
'Cause it's too hot!
Aww, man....
People are JUST starving, that's...
That's the long and the short of it, people are just starving.
They are.
Duplicants died, more people died.
Dan...
Is just dead. The bodies are piling up.
Bubbles is just down here, dying.
I have to....
They're breaking X(?)-
They broke every single one of these?
Every one of these, are you kidding me?
God dammit it's a never ending nightmare!
Just let me help you!
I know how to do it now!
God dammit, you gotta be kidding me.
I know how to help.
Why is this so hard?
Stinky, GOD DAMMIT.
It's always the ones that I CARE ABOUT!
God fucking dammit.
UGH!
God dammit!
This is the episode of DEATH!
This is the episode of literally nothing but death!
God, everyone is starving. I just can't make enough food!
(Sighs)
I just can't make enough food.
More people are gonna die.
There... there's just nothing I can do about it. These are gonna grow slowly.
And there's just nothing we can do.
It's gonna reach a point where...
I-I-I can't bring anyone in.
What are they gonna do? Nothing.
It's gonna reach a point of equilibrium, when there's...
You know, when there's...
Enough people that there's not a food shortage anymore because everyone's dying.
Or everyone has died, but I may as well get more people in here.
Meep. Aww fuck, Meep... Did Meep die?
I dunno...
(sad sigh)
Frick.
I'll just get...
Turner.
I'm sorry I'm so sad, like...
I'm not joking when I say, like, I-I don't want these guys to die.
It's just... super weird.
I dunno what it is.
I just... It's not like I actually have physical feelings for them but, it's just...
Like, it's such bullshit that...
Just.
Surrounded by nothing but death.
I need this thing to get more...
like, be in the contaminated oxygen enough, such that it makes more slime.
'Cause it comes down here every once in a while, and then it floats back up.
I think what I gotta do is I gotta like...
I gotta like, destroy this stuff?
Just kinda perforate the bottom of it.
You know, so people can still jump across it but, you know.
People are still starving. There's six- two more. God, two more people have died.
Two more.
Someone died building a grave stone.
(very quietly) Good God...
I thought I had this turned around. I thought I had this figured out.
And then just, all of this shit happened.
So...
The only thing I could do,
Is I could make Microbe *Mushers, in here.
And then destroy all the other ones.
These are closer to the water, so they would naturally be able to...
You know...
Like...
Naturally you'd just logically be able to make faster.
Just by pure...
Distance.
So if we set these at a high priority to make these.
I mean I know it's not a good use of...
The uh, the resources that we have. I'm, I'm well aware of that.
I wish it weren't the case, and I wish we didn't have bodies literally piling up.
God dammit, and the fucking...
OVERHEATED!!!??
Overheated???
Is it 'cause of...?
Is it 'cause of Bubbles's rotting body?
God dammit, we gotta build more grave stones.
Jesus...
We're down to six.
Four more people have died.
Stacy.
Mae.
Virgil.
Woodrow.
I don't...
God dammit...
I thought I had it. I THOUGHT I had IT, with that...
Fucking FILTER!
It provided MORE WATER. How did it go...
From- I had plenty of food! How did this happen?!
God, we can't make power, we can't do anything, we're not repairing things.
Ugh, fuck....
They can't make any food, they can't even repair. They're literally just going to die.
The Meal... I should have been making Mealwood before.
God dammit...
They're just gonna tear themselves apart until it's the end.
Aww man...
There's nothing else to do, they are all going to die.
I built all this infrastructure.
I built all of this in the hopes that I would turn this around and I still failed.
There's no coming back from this.
There's just not, there's no coming back from this.
Mozzarella, he's been here forever.
Nizbit, he's a new arrival.
I know what I did wrong.
I know what I did wrong, because obviously I didn't know what I was doing.
Number one, but I know what I did wrong.
In terms of the way I build the layout.
I was fighting 100% stress,
the ENTIRE game!
And I was doing it. I was SO CLOSE to succeeding!
And then FOOD gets me?
God dammit...
I'm devastated.
I really am, I really am, I really am devastated.
I...
Like, everything was against me. Yes, everything was against me.
Like, I still can't believe this game is in pre-Alpha. It's not even a Beta.
And fuck, I love it.
I love this game. I love this game. I can't stop playing this game!
Ugh, until it removed all choice from me.
And then it ended everything for me.
Oh man.
I tried.
I was learning as I was going, you can't fault me for that.
I don't think you do. I think you guys are on my side for it.
But I'm just like, I'm complaining to the like,
To fate itself.
You can't fault me for trying!
Like I was learning as I was going, and I was loving every minute of learning it.
And I haven't had a game like this that makes me just...
Itch to play it more.
And even right now. I wanna go back and I wanna dive in and
I wanna start over again with everything that I learned and I will do that!
But not today.
So thank you everybody so much for watching! Hope you guys have enjoyed this thus far.
I tried really hard, and I've learned a lot.
And, if I go back in there, I'm gonna make,
A fricking amazing base!
But I scratched the surface of it.
I didn't even get past the first biome!
Of the normal base materials, I didn't even go far enough to see where we could've gone.
(sigh)
Well hopefully we will soon.
So thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you...
In the next video!
Buh-bye!